mr speaker
the president
of the united states
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't use it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
of the congress
i have the distinct privilege
and the high personal honor
of presenting to you
the president of the united states
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker
mr president my colleagues in the
congress our distinguished guests
my fellow americans
we meet here tonight at a time of great
challenge
and great opportunities for america
we meet at a time when we face great
problems at home and abroad that will
test the strength of our fiber as a
nation
but we also meet at a time when that
fiber has been tested and it has proved
strong
america is a great and good land
and we are a great and good land because
we are a strong free creative people
and because america is the single
greatest force for peace anywhere in the
world
[Music]
[Applause]
today as always in our history
we can base our confidence in what the
american people will achieve in the
future on the record of what the
american people have achieved in the
past
tonight
for the first time in 12 years
a president of the united states can
report to the congress
on the state of a union at peace with
every nation of the world
[Music]
[Applause]
because of this
in the 22 000 word message on the state
of the union that i have just handed to
the speaker of the house and the
president of the senate
i have been able to deal primarily with
the problems of peace with what we can
do here at home in america for the
american people rather than with the
problems of war
the measures i have outlined in this
message set an agenda for truly
significant progress for this nation and
the world in 1974.
before we chart where we are going
let us see how far
we have come
it was five years ago on the steps of
this capital that i took the oath of
office as your president
in those five years
because of the initiatives undertaken by
this administration
the world has changed
america has changed
as a result of those changes america is
safer today
more prosperous today with greater
opportunity for more of its people than
ever before in our history
five years ago
america was at war in southeast asia
we were locked in confrontation with the
soviet union
we were in hostile isolation from a
quarter of the world's people who lived
in mainland china
five years ago our cities were burning
and besieged five years ago our college
campuses were a battleground
five years ago
crime was increasing
at a rate that struck fear across the
nation
five years ago the spiraling rise in
drug addiction was threatening human and
social tragedy of massive proportion and
there was no program to deal with it
five years ago
as young americans had done for a
generation before that
america's youth still live under the
shadow
of the military draft
five years ago there was no national
program to preserve our environment
day by day our air
was getting dirtier
our water was getting more foul
and five years ago american agriculture
was practically a depressed industry
with a hundred thousand farm families
abandoning the farm every year
as we look at america today we find
ourselves challenged by new problems
but we also find a record of progress
to confound
the professional criers of doom and
prophets of despair
we met the challenges we faced five
years ago
and we will be equally confident of
meeting those that we face today
[Applause]
let us see for a moment how we have met
them
after more than 10 years of military
involvement
all of our troops every term from
southeast asia and they have returned
with honor
[Applause]
[Music]
and we can be proud of the fact that our
courageous prisoners of war for whom a
dinner was held in washington tonight
that they came home with their heads
high on their feet and not on their
knees
[Music]
in our relations with the soviet union
we have turned away from a policy of
confrontation to one of negotiation
for the first time since world war ii
the world's two strongest powers are
working together
toward peace in the world
with the people's republic of china
after a generation of hostile isolation
we have begun a period of peaceful
exchange and expanding trade
peace has returned to our cities
to our campuses
the 17-year rise in crime has been
stopped
we can confidently say today that we are
finally beginning to win the war against
crime
right here in this nation's capital
which a few years ago was threatening to
become the crime capital of the world
the raid in crime has been cut in half
a massive campaign against drug abuse
has been organized
and the rate of new heroin addiction the
most vicious threat of all
is decreasing rather than increasing
for the first time in a generation
no young americans are being drafted
into the armed services of the united
states
[Music]
for the first time ever we have
organized a massive national effort to
protect the environment our air is
getting cleaner
our water is getting pure and our
agriculture which was depressed is
prospering farm income is up 70 percent
farm production is setting all-time
records
and the billions of dollars the
taxpayers were paying in subsidies has
been cut to nearly zero
overall
americans are living more abundantly
than ever before
today
more than two and a half million new
jobs were
created in the past year alone
that is the biggest percentage increase
in nearly 20 years people are earning
more
what they earn buys more
more than ever before in history
in the past five years the average
americans real spendable income
that is what you really can buy with
your income
even after allowing for taxes and
inflation has increased by 16
despite this record of achievement
as we turn to the year ahead
we hear once again the familiar voice of
the perennial prophets of gloom
telling us now
that because of the need to fight
inflation
because of the energy shortage
america may be headed for a recession
well let me speak to that issue head on
there will be no recession in the united
states of america
primarily due to our energy crisis our
economy is passing through a difficult
period
but i pledge to you tonight that the
full powers of this government will be
used to keep america's economy producing
and to protect the jobs of america's
workers
[Applause]
we are engaged in a long and hard fight
against inflation
there have been and there will be in the
future ups and downs in that fight
but if this congress cooperates in our
efforts to hold down the cost of
government we shall win our fight to
hold down the cost of living for the
american people
[Music]
[Applause]
as we look back over our history
the years that stand out as the ones of
signal achievement
are those in which the administration
and the congress whether one party or
the other
working together
had the wisdom and the foresight
to select those particular initiatives
for which the nation was ready and the
moment was right
and in which they seized the moment
and acted
looking at the year 1974 which lies
before us
there are ten key areas in which
landmark accomplishments are possible
this year
in america
if we make these our national agenda
this is what we will achieve in 1974.
we will break the back of the energy
crisis we will lay the foundation for
our future capacity to meet america's
energy needs from america's own
resources
[Applause]
[Music]
and we will take another giant stride
toward lasting peace in the world not
only by continuing our policy of
negotiation rather than confrontation
where the great powers are concerned
but also by helping toward the
achievement
of a just and lasting settlement in the
middle east
we will check the rise in prices without
administering the harsh medicine of
recession
we will make our states and localities
more responsive to the needs of their
own citizens
we will make a crucial breakthrough
toward better transportation in our
towns and in our cities across america
we will reform our system of federal aid
to education
to provide it when it is needed
where it is needed so that it will do
the most for those who need it the most
[Applause]
we will make an historic beginning on
the task of defining and protecting the
right of personal privacy for every
american
and we will start on a new road toward
reform
of a welfare system
that bleeds the taxpayer corrodes the
community and demeans those it is
intended to assist
and together
with the other nations of the world
we will establish the economic framework
within within which americans will share
more fully
in an expanding worldwide trade and
prosperity in the years ahead
with more open access to both markets
and supplies
in all of the
186 state of the union messages
delivered from this place
in our history
this is the first
in which the one
priority the first priority is energy
let me begin by reporting a new
development which i know will be welcome
news to every american
as you know
we have committed ourselves to an active
role in helping to achieve a just and
durable peace in the middle east
on the basis of full implementation of
security council resolutions 242 and 338
the first step in the process is the
disengagement of egyptian and israeli
forces which is now taking place
because of this hopeful development
i can announce tonight
that i have been assured through my
personal contacts with friendly leaders
in the middle eastern area
that an urgent meeting will be called in
the immediate future to discuss the
lifting of the oil embargo
now this
this is an encouraging sign however it
should be clearly understood by our
friends in the middle east that the
united states will not be coerced on
this issue
regardless of the outcome of this
meeting the cooperation of the american
people in our energy conservation
program has already gone a long way
towards achieving a goal to which i am
deeply dedicated
let us do everything we can to avoid
gasoline rationing in the united states
last week
i sent to the congress a comprehensive
special message setting forth our energy
situation recommending the legislative
measures which are necessary to a
program for meeting our needs
if the embargo is lifted this will ease
the crisis but it will not mean an end
to the energy shortage in america
voluntary conservation will continue to
be necessary
and let me take this occasion
to pay tribute once again to the
splendid spirit of cooperation the
american people have shown which has
made possible our success in meeting
this emergency up to this time
the new legislation i have requested
will also remain necessary
therefore i urge again
that the energy measures that i have
proposed be made the first priority of
this session of the congress
these measures will require the oil
companies and other enemy energy
producers
to provide the public with the necessary
information on their supplies
they will prevent the injustice of
windfall profits for a few as a result
of the sacrifices of the millions of
americans
[Applause]
they will give us the organization the
incentives the authorities
needed to deal with the short-term
emergency and to move toward meeting our
long-term needs
just as 1970 was the year in which we
began a full-scale effort to protect the
environment
1974
must be the year in which we organize a
full-scale effort to provide for our
energy needs not only in this decade but
through the 21st century
as we move toward
the celebration two years from now
at the 200th anniversary of this
nation's
let us press vigorously on toward the
goal that i announced last november for
project independence
let this be our national goal
at the end of this decade in the year
1980 the united states will not be
dependent on any other country for the
energy we need to provide our jobs to
heat our homes and to keep our
transportation moving
[Music]
to indicate the size of the government
commitment
to spur energy research and development
we plan to spend 10 billion in federal
funds over the next five years
that is an enormous amount
but during the same five years private
enterprise will be investing as much as
200 billion dollars
and in 10 years 500 billion dollars to
develop the new resources the new
technology the new capacity america will
require for its energy needs in the
1980s
that's just a measure
of the magnitude of the project we are
undertaking
but america performs best
when called to its biggest tasks
it can truly be said
that only in america
could a task so tremendous be achieved
so quickly
and achieved not by regimentation
but through the effort and ingenuity of
our free people working in a free system
turning now to the rest of the agenda
for 1974 the time is at hand this year
to bring comprehensive high quality
health care within the reach of every
american
i shall propose a sweeping new program
that will assure comprehensive health
insurance protection to millions of
americans who cannot now obtain it or
afford it with vastly improved
protection against catastrophic
illnesses
this will be a plan that maintains the
high standards of quality in america's
health care
and it will not require additional taxes
[Applause]
now i recognize
that other plans have been put forward
that would cost 80 billions
or even 100 billion dollars
and that would put our whole health care
system under the heavy hand of the
federal government
this is the wrong approach
this has been tried abroad and it's
failed
it is not the way we do things here in
america
this kind of plan would threaten the
quality of care provided by our whole
health care system
the right way
is one that builds on the strengths of
the present system and one
and that does not destroy those
strengths
one based on partnership not paternalism
most important of all
let us keep this
as the guiding principle
of our health programs
government has a great role to play
but we must always make sure
that our doctors will be working for
their patients and not for the federal
government
many of you will recall that in my state
of the union address three years ago i
commented that most americans today are
simply fed up with government at all
levels i recommended a sweeping set of
proposals to revitalize state and local
government
to make them more responsive to the
people they serve
i can report to you today
that as a result of revenue sharing
passed by the congress and other
measures
we have made progress toward that goal
after 40 years of moving power from the
states
and the communities to washington dc
we have begun moving power
back from washington to the states and
communities and most important to the
people of america
[Applause]
in this session of the congress
i believe we are near the breakthrough
point on efforts
which i have suggested proposals
to let people themselves make their own
decisions for their own communities and
in particular on those to provide broad
new flexibility
in federal aid
for community development for economic
development for education
and i look forward to working with the
congress with members of both parties in
resolving whatever remaining differences
we have in this legislation
so that we can make available nearly
five and a half billion dollars to our
states and localities to use
not for what a federal bureaucrat may
want
but for what their own people in those
communities want
the decision should be there
i think all of us recognize that the
energy crisis has given
new urgency to the need to improve
public transportation
not only in our cities but in rural
areas as well
the program i propose this year
will give communities not only more
money but also more freedom to balance
their own transportation needs
it will mark the strongest federal
commitment ever to the improvement of
mass transit as an essential element of
the improvement of life in our towns and
cities
[Applause]
one goal
on which all americans agree
is that our children should have the
very best education this great nation
can provide
in a special message last week i
recommended a number of important new
measures
that can make 1974 a year of truly
significant advances for our schools and
for the children they serve
if the congress will act on these
proposals
more flexible funding will enable each
federal dollar to meet better the pr
particular need of each particular
school district
advanced funding will give school
authorities a chance
to make each year's plans knowing ahead
of time what federal funds they're going
to receive
special targeting will give special help
to the truly disadvantaged among our
people
college students faced with rising costs
for their education will be able to draw
on an expanded program of loans and
grants
these advances are a needed investment
in america's most precious resource
our next generation
and i urge the congress to act in this
legislation
in 1974.
one measure
of a truly free society
is the vigor with which it protects the
liberties of its individual citizens
as technology has advanced in america it
is increasingly encroached on one of
those liberties
what i term the right of personal
privacy
modern information systems data banks
credit records mailing list abuses
electronic snooping the collection of
personal data for one purpose that may
be used for another all these
have left millions of americans deeply
concerned by the privacy they cherish
and the crime has come therefore
for a major initiative
to define the nature and extent of the
basic rights of privacy and to erect new
safeguards to ensure that those rights
are respected
i shall launch such an effort
this year at the highest levels of the
administration
and i look forward again to working with
this congress
and establishing a new set of standards
that respect the legitimate needs of
society
but that also recognize personal privacy
as a cardinal principle of american
liberty
[Applause]
nation's welfare system a monstrous
consuming outrage
an outrage against the community against
the taxpayer
and particularly against the children
that it is supposed to help
that system is still an outrage
by improving its administration we have
been able to reduce some of the abuses
as a result last year for the first time
in 18 years there has been a halt in the
growth of the welfare caseload
but as a system
our welfare program
still needs reform as urgently today as
it did when i first proposed in 1969
that we completely replace it with a
different system
in these final three years of my
administration i urge the congress to
join me
in mounting a major new effort to
replace the discredit
president-present welfare system
with one that works
one that is fair to those who need help
or cannot help themselves
fair to the community and fair to the
taxpayer
and let us have as our goal
that there will be no government program
which it makes it more profitable to go
on welfare than to go to work
i recognize that from the debates that
have taken place within the congress
over the past three years on this
program that we cannot expect enactment
overnight of a new reform
but i do propose that the congress and
administration together
make this the year in which we discuss
debate
and shape such a reform
so that it can be enacted as quickly as
possible
america's own prosperity in the years
ahead
depends on our sharing fully and
equitably in an expanding world
prosperity
historic negotiations will take place
this year that will enable us to ensure
fair treatment in international markets
for american workers american farmers
american investors and american
consumers
it is vital that the authorities
contained in the trade bill i submitted
to the congress be enacted so that the
united states can negotiate flexibly and
vigorously on behalf of american
interests
these negotiations can usher in a new
era of international trade
that not only increases the prosperity
of all nations but also strengthens the
peace
among all nations
in the past five years we have made more
progress toward a lasting structure of
peace in the world
than in any comparable time in the
nation's history
we could not have made that progress
if we had not maintained the military
strength of america
thomas jefferson once observed that the
price of liberty
is eternal vigilance
by the same token and for the same
reason in today's world the price of
peace
is a strong defense
as far as the united states is concerned
in the past five years we have steadily
reduced the burden of national defense
as a share of the budget
bringing it down from 44 in 1969 to 29
in the current year
we have cut our military manpower over
the past five years by more than a third
from three and a half million two and
two tenths period
in the coming year however
increased expenditures will be needed
they will be needed to assure the
continued readiness of our military
forces
to preserve present force levels in the
face of rising costs
and to give us the military strength we
must have if our security is to be
maintained
and if our initiatives for peace
are to succeed
the question is not whether we can
afford to maintain the necessary
strength of our defense
the question is
whether we can afford not to maintain it
and the answer to that question is no we
must never allow america to become the
second strongest nation in the world
i do not say this with any sense of
belligerence
because i recognize the fact it is
recognized around the world
america's military strength has always
been maintained to keep the peace never
to break it
it has always been used to defend
freedom never to destroy it
the world's peace as well as our own
depends on our remaining as strong as we
need to be as long as we need to be
[Applause]
[Applause]
in this year 1974
we will be negotiating with the soviet
union to place further limits on
strategic nuclear arms
together with our allies we will be
negotiating with the nations of the
warsaw pact on mutual and balance
reduction of forces in europe
and we will continue our efforts to
promote peaceful economic development
in latin america in africa in asia
we will press for full compliance with
the priests accords
that brought an end to american fighting
in indochina
including particularly the provision
that promised the fullest possible
accounting for those americans who are
missing in action
and having in mind
the energy crisis to which i referred to
earlier
we will be working with the other
nations of the world toward agreement on
means by which oil supplies can be
assured at reasonable prices on a stable
basis in a fair way to the consuming and
producing nations alike
all of these are steps toward a future
in which the world's peace
and prosperity and ours as well as a
result
are made more secure
throughout the five years that i has
served
as your president
i have had one overriding aim
and that was to establish
a new structure of peace in the world
that can free future generations of the
scourge of war
i can understand that others may have
different priorities
this has been
and this will remain
my first priority
and the chief legacy
i hope to leave from the eight years of
my presidency
[Applause]
as we create more jobs
as we build a better health care system
as we improve our education
as we develop new sources of energy
as we provide more abundantly for the
elderly and the poor
as we strengthen the system of private
enterprise that produces our prosperity
as we do all of this and even more
we solidify those essential bonds that
hold us together as a nation
even more importantly
we advance
what in the final analysis government in
america
is all about
what it is all about is more freedom
more security
a better life for each one of the 211
million people that live in this land
we cannot afford to neglect progress at
home
while pursuing peace abroad
but neither can we afford to neglect
peace abroad
while pursuing progress at home
with a stable peace
all is possible
but without peace
nothing is possible
[Applause]
in the written message that i have just
delivered to the speaker and to the
president of the senate
i commented that one of the continuing
challenges facing us in the legislative
process
is that of the timing and pacing of our
initiatives
selecting each year among many worthy
projects those that are right for action
at that time
what is true in terms of our domestic
initiatives is true also in the world
this period
we now are in in the world
and i say this as one who has seen so
much of the world
not only in these past five years but
going back over many years
we are in a period
which presents a juncture
of historic forces unique in this
century
they provide an opportunity we may never
have again
to create
a structure of peace solid enough to
last a lifetime and more
not just peace in our time
but peace in our children's time as well
it is on the way we respond to this
opportunity
more than anything else that history
will judge whether we in america have
met our responsibility and i am
confident we will meet that great
historic responsibility which is ours
today
it was 27 years ago that
john f kennedy and i
sat in this chamber as freshman
congressman
hearing our first state of the union
address
delivered by harry truman
i know from my talks with him
as members of the labor committee on
which we both served that neither of us
then even dreamed
that either one or both might eventually
be standing in this place that i now
stand in
now
and that he once stood in before me
it may well be
that one of the freshmen members
of the 93rd congress
one of you out there
deliver his own state of the union
message
27 years from now
in the year 2001.
well whichever one it is
i want you to be able to look back with
pride
and to say that your first years here
were great years
and recall that you were here
in this 93rd congress when america ended
its longest war
and began its longest piece
[Applause]
[Applause]
good night
[Music]
mr speaker
and mr president my distinguished
colleagues and our guests
i would like to add a personal word with
regard to an issue that has been
of great concern to all americans over
the past year
i refer of course to the
investigations of the so-called
watergate affair
as you know
i have provided to the special
prosecutor voluntarily
a great deal of material
i believe that i provided all the
material that he needs
to conclude his investigations
and to proceed to prosecute the guilty
and to clear the innocent
i believe the time has come
to bring that investigation and the
other investigations of this matter to
an end
one year of watergate is enough
and the time has come my colleagues for
not only the executive the president
but the members of congress for all of
us to join together
and devoting our full energies
to these great issues that i have
discussed tonight
which involve the welfare of all of the
american people in so many different
ways as well as the peace of the world
i recognize
that the house judiciary committee has a
special responsibility in this area
and i want to indicate on this occasion
that i will cooperate
with the judiciary committee in this
investigation
[Applause]
i will cooperate so that it can conclude
its investigation make its decision
and i will cooperate in any way that i
consider consistent with my
responsibilities to the office of the
presidency of the united states
there is only one limitation
i will follow the president
that has been followed to and defend
followed by and defended by every
president from george washington to
lyndon b johnson
of never doing anything that weakens the
office of the president of the united
states or impairs the ability of the
presidents of the future to make the
great decisions that are so essential to
this nation and the world
[Applause]
another point i should like to make very
briefly
like every member of the house and
senate assembled here tonight
i was elected
to the office that i hold
and like every
member of the house and senate
when i was elected to that office i knew
that i was elected
for the purpose of doing a job
and doing it as well as i possibly can
and i want you to know
that i have no intention whatever of
ever walking away from the job that the
people elected me to do for the people
of the united states
now needless to say it would be
understatement
if i were not to admit that the year
1973 was
not a very easy year for me or
personally or for my family
and as i've already indicated the year
1974 presents very
great and serious problems
as very
great and serious opportunities
are also presented
but my colleagues this i believe
with the help of god who has blessed
this land so richly
with the cooperation of the congress
and with the support of the american
people
we can
and we will
make the year 1974
a year of unprecedented progress toward
our goal
of building a structure of lasting peace
in the world and a new prosperity
without war in the united states of
america
richard nixon is the focus this week in
our series american president's life
portraits friday here on c-span will be
live from the nixon birthplace and
presidential library in yorba linda
california
we'll take your phone calls as we
examine his life and career
it gets underway at 5 pm eastern
as we approach the end of our series
american president's life portraits you
can again see our video records of a